Peter Kings on right now and I don't
know if you saw what Adam Schefter just
reported and it lends credence to some
rumors I've been hearing for some time
that for some reason DeAndre Hopkins was
not in favor in Houston and Adam
Schefter reporting Peter that as part of
the trade that brings David Johnson to
Houston
it is DeAndre Hopkins going to Arizona
it's kind of crazy yeah what is that
I mean first of all thank you for
calling in today how are you thank you
for thank you for having me can I tell
you the origin of DeAndre Hopkins and
all this stuff MA
so toward the end of the year I had
heard that DeAndre Hopkins was not
altogether happy in Houston and that
they were not altogether happy with his
performance now you know how much of
that stuff that you hear is real how
much isn't it real I just sort of filed
it away and at the Scouting Combine
someone who I know well told me you know
they might be serious about Lou and
DeAndre Hopkins so I filed that away
again and so last week when I was on the
phone getting ready for this column this
obviously this is a big column when you
do the the the first week of free agency
in and and along with the incredible
confluence of events with the you know
the new CBA and coronavirus are talking
to a lot of people and there's a rich
there was there was another team low in
the first round of his draft that was
actively working on DeAndre Hopkins in
the last seven days okay and when I say
working on him I mean studying tape and
and all that and so I just I wrote it
you know but but I said who knows you
know I didn't I didn't know that he was
going to be traded today at all
but this really doesn't shock me but now
look there's got to be something else
involved and I think what else must be
involved is a prominent draft choice
because Bill O'Brien
desperately wants draft capital to
rebuild his team well I mean a John
McClain our good friend from Houston
Chronicle who knows everything about
everything about Houston sports and
certainly the Texans and this is why I
love having you on right now Peter and I
appreciate you calling in again and you
know talking about breaking news like
this
John McLane says that it's DeAndre and a
fourth to the Cardinals for David
Johnson and a second this year and a
fourth rounder next year it is a fantasy
football trait essentially you know this
is actually happening right now Peter
well when you say I want you to think
about this to everybody is going to say
oh my god this is crazy Bill O'Brien
this is a rapacious trade it's it's
horrible for her for Houston but just
remember a couple of things all right
this is and this is really important to
remember and again look I
you're just you're telling me about this
trade right now and I didn't know when
you just started talking to me about it
right sure everybody's gonna say oh my
god there it just wasn't enough it just
wasn't enough well I'll tell you why it
seems like this isn't enough and it's a
very very simple reason because DeAndre
Hopkins is an 8-year player
I think he's 28 years old this year you
know and and if you look at what is so
important about the market right now
there is no position in this draft
it is far and away that has as many good
players in it as his wide receiver and
so if I'm looking at this right now what
I'm saying about it is that the most
important element of this trade is
certainly not David Johnson it's that
whatever would be the I don't know
35th pick overall or whatever they the
Cardinals I don't even know what it is
38 pick overall I don't know but that is
why Bill O'Brien did this deal it's
still a shocker right I mean DeAndre
Hopkins is a trucker but rich I and I
don't mean to keep interrupting but I do
want hopefully just one other point I'm
sorry I didn't but I just want to I just
want to say that at this time all right
you have to ask yourself you know it's
only a three million dollar cap yet to
get rid of DeAndre Hopkins right now and
if you feel like he has played his best
football and he might be on the other
side of that right now if you feel that
and if you can get the thirty fifth pick
in a pretty good Draft knowing that you
might be able to get the next DeAndre
Hopkins and if I'm not mistaken DeAndre
Hopkins was about the 27th pick in
whatever was 11 or 12 so you know I
don't know I I maybe it's because I
don't I don't think of it in terms of oh
my god I love DeAndre Hopkins as a
player and I really like him as a player
but I understand why Houston do it well
I got to tell you just to fill in the
blanks here Arizona has the 40th overall
selection in round 2 and yes you're
right I mean the wide receiving group
was spectacular at the combine Peter and
you know somebody like the Raider is
sitting there 12th overall might be the
might get there first
may have their pick of the entire class
because of how great stat the top 10 is
and and all of that
interesting rich isn't it interesting
that what we have seen with the wide
receiver group in the last few years
look at last year you know Perry
maclaurins 76 the overall DK Metcalf
64th overall you know you could be both
Samuel second-round pick and and McBrine
it's great I'm with a failure rate death
I'm with
Peter but how many of those are gonna
blossom into DeAndre Hopkins and I mean
you've got to sit here and think of here
if you're an Arizona Cardinal fan you're
like okay Larry's coming back
Kenyan Drake did what he did now DeAndre
Hopkins and Larry Fitzgerald don't you
Oh big time and now kind of 98 million
bucks for one year for Kenyan Drake
after the way he played in that offense
last year and I gotta tell you I'll tell
you this cliff Kings where he thinks he
died with heaven and and last year Peter
and I'll give it up to you know the
Cardinals and and at this point last
year you're wondering what a Steve chyme
thinking why would they do this to Josh
Rosen and the way they handled it was
was something that that needed to be you
know addressed right now I'll tell you
what man this is an incredible button
pushed because David Johnson is
significant but less of a loss when
you've got Kenyan Drake who you picked
up you know cents on the dollar in the
middle of last season in Kyler's Murray
coming off an offensive Rookie of the
Year campaign with DeAndre oh yeah
I mean calm yeah that is yeah think of
it rich
you know how motivated DeAndre Hopkins
is going to be to stick it to the the
the Texan you know you gave up on me and
all this stuff even though I believe he
wanted to go and and and but there's one
other little point in this if you're
DeAndre Hopkins aren't you thinking
right now hey I got three years left on
my deal and it's at about ten or eleven
million or whatever I forget what it is
maybe maybe like twelve million a year
and he's probably thinking I want to get
paid so he's gonna go to Arizona this
year and be hugely motivated to have a
very very big year for the Arizona
Cardinals Peter came here on the Rich
Eisen show okay Peter I give you the
floor and what the dak Prescott
franchising means I don't think it means
a lot other than the Dallas Cowboys have
totally mishandled this situation they
screwed it up totally totally screwed
this up rich when you have a quarterback
who's good
he's almost ready to get paid you better
pay him you know because the only thing
that happens is if you delay it it's
only going to cost you money how much
money do you think the Ryan Tannehill
contract has cost the Dallas Cowboys
it's cost them money because now Ryan
Tannehill with 91 million dollars in the
first three years of his contract this
is the fourth highest amount of money
that a quarterback has ever gotten in
the first three years of a contract and
so in that Prescott is look at that and
just laughing because that contract is
gonna mean that that dak Prescott just
made more money yesterday because
eventually they got a seinem long-term
and I just I think the Ryan Tannehill
contract has got to make Jerry and
Steven Jones just gulp and say man why
didn't we get this done last offseason
and the Derrick Henry contract would be
what because they II got slapped with a
franchise tag you know if you saw a tire
in Matthew go out on Twitter and wonder
why they Titans paint a quarterback I
get that I don't you get that I mean
Tyrann Mathieu is you know I but but
rich I'm sorry you don't pay running
backs and I know everybody's gonna say
well you you got to pay you got to pay
Derrick Henry well maybe but tell me
when is the last big contract for a
running back when do you ever look at
that three years into it and say uh-huh
what a bargain you saying that with
Ezekiel Elliott right now no I mean
you're gonna say that on fake on Barkley
second contract I mean maybe but it just
it doesn't happen those things don't
work so I mean that's the way it is if
you if you want to make a huge amount of
money in the NFL
don't play running back Peter King here
from NBC Sports on the Rich Eisen show
well one thing you're saying about a few
years in that man this contract looks a
little cheap or inexpensive is Garoppolo
based on what you're seeing of what
Tannehill hit and what franchise tag
rate Prescott hit and also Kirk Cousins
signing for 33 million bucks
for two extra years his agent I texted
them today and I said hey Mike you know
what you got to do you have to go teach
a class and you know a negotiating class
in a business school your entire
syllabus you can just hand out a
syllabus with two works on it Kirk
Cousins do you know I'll tell you what
Peter he's the ease that Darrelle Revis
of quarterbacks
you know just killing it with contracts
that aren't any longer than three years
two years three years franchised year
after year so the reason why I brought
up Garoppolo is my way of taking this
conversation in the Tom Brady direction
the tiny-house signing and where things
stand on right now at Tom Brady best you
can tell us what I don't know don't know
I had thought for a long time that it at
the end the Patriots were gonna have a
chance and it was going to be up to Bill
Belichick they certainly don't seem to
be moving very aggressively toward doing
that and one other thing about the
Patriots rich they just for the next two
years have committed a combined 14
million dollars in they were already a
cash-strapped cap strap team to Matthew
Slater and Devin McCourty McCord Ian
Slater in that order so I mean at some
point I don't know where all the money
is coming from but I I still think I've
said it all along I think it's probably
more likely than not that he signs
elsewhere I've heard about all the Tampa
stuff it wouldn't shock me I've thought
for a long time that it was going to be
Teddy Bridgewater but I'm sure Bruce
Arians like every offensive coach in
modern NFL history has to say man I'd
love it I'd love to get my my hands on
Tom Brady so I mean who knows well see
well the Bucks went ahead and in
franchise to Shaq Barrett so yeah it
looks like that was that that was about
that one was a pretty expected deal well
I guess that means what for Jamison
they have money to sign Brady if they
want there is that a fit though Peter I
mean for Brady and for for it for Tom do
you think that's a fit for Tom obviously
no I mean everybody might say that he
doesn't have deep arm that that you know
that Bruce Arians would want I always
thought that that was a myth about
through Syrians you think of Bruce
Arians doesn't have the strongest arm
quarterback but he's going to come in
and say all right tom we're throwing
five 40 yard outs every game you know or
whatever word he's going to coach the
guy who we have and if you think right
now that Bruce Arians would like a
strong-armed quarterback over a smart
winning quarterback I just I think
that's wrong I've always thought that
his offense fits everybody and is a
delight for you know a Brett Favre
Michael Vick arm okay Brady doesn't have
that right now he'll live and you think
that Chris Godwin and Mike Evans are
saying oh my god we can't run as many go
routes anymore their kids on Christmas
if they open up their their their free
agent gift and and it's and it's Tom
Brady so I I don't I don't think that
everybody should be so should be as
hugely interested in what kind of deep
arm Tom Brady at 43 years well I guess
the way I was trying to say it I should
have put a finer point on it was that
you know if it comes down to it
returning to New England finishing his
career as a patriot and knowing that
you're always in a division and with a
coaching staff and with a situation that
you've got a chance to win it going in
as opposed to putting on puter for the
first time and I'm not saying that's a
bad thing
just ask Warren Sapp and our buddies you
know Lynch and Brooks etc I'm just
pointing it out that it's just such a
change that he would be always
remembered he finished up with Tampa and
not in New England that he would make
that he'd make that decision we get
things about that number one I remember
being in training camp
Denver Broncos went 43 or 42 euros Jerry
Rice was trying to make the Mike
Shanahan Broncos very late in his career
obviously and I remember watching him
watching him get covered by a free
engine cornerback from Bowling Green and
I said oh my god this is this is sad and
everything like that and everybody at
the time was saying oh my god his legacy
will be tarnished no one in your
listening audience even remembers he was
in training camp with the desert nobody
remembers him as a Seahawk or barely
remembers him as a Raider it didn't
tarnish his legacy that's number one
number two Jeff Darlington was on this
you know the ESPN reported the excellent
ESPN reporter was on this forever and he
he said you know hey Tom Brady just
might want some sort of new experience
everybody said oh my god can only go to
a place where you can win in challenge
to win a Super Bowl you know Tom Brady
is more of an experiential guy and I and
I'll just finish by saying this one
thing that last year the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers were seven and seven going
into the last few games of the year
against Houston and Atlanta at home they
outplayed each one of those teams in
those two games except for one thing
Jameis Winston threw six interceptions
and so all I'm saying is that easily
Tampa Bay could have been nine and seven
or ten and six last year and I mean
easily right their quarterback turned it
over 36 times you know including fumbles
so you know it's it's I don't think the
Bucs are that far away Peter and I've
got about a couple minutes left can you
tell me if it's still and it's just been
amazing going down this wormhole or just
talking sports right but is it possible
it is it been is it possible that the
new league gear still gets pushed
because of everything that's going on in
the world Peter you know I rich I got
the sense last night that the NFL was
you know had no intention of moving it
but they've gotten so much pushback
you know from from not only the media
but from their general managers I called
it tell them today or outrage just
outrage that Adam Schefter I thought he
was gonna blow a fuse last night on
SportsCenter when he was talking to the
impelled about about what he had heard
yeah I mean either he's talking to the
same people I'm talking to or something
but there were people last night who
were incredulous that it wasn't going to
be moved now I think the NFLPA
and I think there are some owners also
who believe that hey look you know when
is it going to be a good time in the
next two months to conduct our regularly
scheduled business and I'm not defending
him I'm saying that here is what I was
hearing yesterday not only this is an
outrage but others saying I mean we got
it we got to conduct our business and we
don't want to be having free agency on
July 8th and the draft on July 29th you
know so I I can see it both ways but I
certainly see that the NFL is in the
horns of a dilemma here just my gut
feeling is they're going to go ahead
with it as normal now that they've
started the the tampering period Peter
thanks for the call you will and
everybody else you know being well
hunkered down yeah every everybody's
good were were were hunkered down in
Brooklyn and and if this is as bad as it
gets I think we could all handle it
right back at you Peter thanks to the
call we'll chat soon hopefully thank you
Rick right back at you Peter King at
Peter underscore King on Twitter